bonjour à tous
est ce que vous connaissez emmanuel kant
mal quand c'est un philosophe dont le
nom est assez connu généralement on a
beaucoup plus de mal quand il s'agit de
définir ou de résumer sa pensée je
trouve qu emmanuel kant il est connu
pour plusieurs choses pour plusieurs
oeuvres et on va commencer par le
définir de la manière la plus générale
quand c'est d'abord un philosophe des
lumières philosophes du xviiie siècle
les lumières allemand de qu'on appelait
à toutes les rondes
il a d'ailleurs écrit un petit ouvrage
pour exposer la philosophie des lumières
qui s'appelle qu'est ce que les lumières
publié en 1784 est ce que dit quand dans
cet ouvrage c'est que les lumières selon
lui c'est la sortie de l'humanité or de
l'état de tutelle dont elle est elle
même responsable
l'état de crise tel c'est-à-dire fait
que l'humanité d'été parents autonome
intellectuellement moralement
philosophiquement et que c'est seulement
à partir la pensée des lumières que
l'humanité a commencé à s'émanciper de
ce joug du pouvoir qu'elle a commencé à
penser par elle-même
de la même façon qu'on dit qu'un adulte
pense par lui-même contrairement à
l'enfant et d'ailleurs c'est un petit
moyen mnémotechnique que je vous donne
pour retenir le siècle des lumières en
france actuellement la majorité est à 18
ans c'est au xviiie siècle selon kant
que l'humanité est devenue majeure elle
a commencé à prendre ses propres
décisions à être responsable et autonome
vous allez voir que ce n'est pas
étranger à ce dont on va parler
aujourd'hui
quand est également connu pour l'un des
ouvrages majeurs de la philosophie
moderne en termes de théorie la
connaissance qui est la critique de la
raison pure alors vous préviens c'est un
ouvrage extrêmement ardu et l'ont très
compliqué mais sa lecture en vaut
l'effort en vaut le sacrifice est ce que
propose quand c'est une sorte de voie
médiane de synthèse entre le
rationalisme cartésien
c'est à dire l'idée que la logique
les idées sont premières par rapport à
l'expérience
synthèse de ce rationalisme cartésien et
de l'empirisme de david yum puisque
quand explique avoir été réveillé de son
sommeil dogmatique par la lecture de yum
c'est à dire qu'il a compris à cette
occasion qu'on pouvait pas résumer la
connaissance simplement à la logique
cure simplement au monde des idées comme
dirait platon la connaissance c'est
aussi de l'expérience c'est aussi du
contact sensorielle avec le monde et
quand a tenu à prendre en compte cette
dimension expérimentale de la
connaissance dans son système théorique
critique de la raison pure dont il a été
publié en 1781 puis en 1787 et enfin la
troisième raison pour laquelle compte
généralement reconnus c'est pour sa
philosophie morale une philosophie
morale qu'il expose entre autres dans un
petit livre qui s'appelle fondements de
la métaphysique des moeurs et dont on va
parler dans cette vidéo
alors avant d'aller dans nos coeur de la
pensée qu'on sienne on va déjà dire
quelques mots sur l'homme alors quand
pour ceux qui ont vu ma vidéo sur le
pouvoir de l'habitude
vous savez que c'était un homme qui
avait un mode de vie extrêmement
régulier extrêmement neely mettrais et
très monotone
c'est quelqu'un qui n'aimait pas
visiblement l'imprévu qui aimait que sa
vie soit parfaitement réglée et c'est un
personnage qu'on pourrait sans prendre
de risques
qualifiée d' austère c'était quelqu'un
qui a tâché énormément d'importance à la
règle au principe vous allez voir que sa
philosophie morale et est imprégnée de
ce trait de caractère
autre détail important c'est que quand
tu étais un philosophe croyant
protestants mais que ses croyances
religieuses n'intervienne pour ainsi
dire pas dans son système de pensée y
compris même dans son système de pensée
morale si vous préférez quand tu n'es
pas un auteur qui va convoquer dieu pour
justifier ses conceptions morales quand
tu vas au contraire asseoir sa morale sa
conception de la morale sur des concepts
philosophiques qui n'empruntent rien à
la religion mais qui au contraire
emprunt qui tout à la raison c'est à
dire à ce qu'il fait selon lui le propre
de l'homme
donc on va les voir un petit peu ce qui
se cache derrière les fondements de la
métaphysique des moeurs on va essayer de
comprendre comment se construit la
morale kantienne et on va voir jusqu'à
quel point
et cette vision peut être considérée
comme intéressante valable et pertinente
on devait résumer les fondements de la
métaphysique des moeurs de kant pour
dire que c'est l'exposition détaillée de
ce que quand tu appelles un impératif
catégorique
qu'est ce qu'un impératif catégorique
c'est le principe moral qui doit nous
guider dans notre comportement
c'est la norme de conduite que l'être
humain doit adopter
alors avant d'aller plus loin il faut
déjà faire un petit rappel sur ce qu'est
la morale en elle-même qu'est ce que la
morale la morale c'est un système de
normes
c'est un ensemble de règles que l'on se
prescrit ou que l'on prescrit aux autres
et qui est censé nous guider vers le
bien
derrière toute morale il y a une
conception du bien il y as distinction
entre eux le principe du bien et le
principe du mal donc la morale ne peut
pas être envisagée en dehors de cette
distinction entre le bien et le mal
si vous préférez enlevé les mots bien et
mal notabiliaires philosophique la
morale n'existe plus donc la morale
c'est d'abord ça c'est d'abord le
principe selon lequel nous devrions
tendre vers le bien et nous éloigner du
mal mais vous voyez immédiatement le
problème que ça pose c'est que le bien
et le mal peuvent être considérés comme
des notion très subjective
en réalité personne n'est absolument
d'accord sur ce qu'on appelle le bien
sûr ce qu'on appelle le mal et la
plupart des conflits des accords ou des
malentendus sur la question morale
proviennent justement de cette
différence de définition du bien et du
mal
alors pour bien comprendre cette morale
kantienne on pourrait déjà commencer par
dire à quoi elles s'opposent
la morale qu'ancienne s'oppose à ce
qu'on appelle l'utilitarisme sur lequel
j'ai fait une vidéo récemment et
l'utilitarisme c'est l'idée que nos
actions ne doivent être évalués c'est à
dire on ne doit leur prêter de valeur
qu'à la lumière de leurs conséquences
on analyse les conséquences de notre
action en termes de plaisir et de
douleur et si une action produit plus de
plaisir globale que de douleur le bal à
ce moment là cette action sera
considérée comme moralement bonne ça
c'est le principe de l'utilitarisme plus
grand bonheur des plus grand nombre
calculé downeast qui fait qu'on va juger
la valeur morale d'une action à l'aune
de ses conséquences en termes de plaisir
et de souffrance or pour compte
cette vision là est totalement absurde
quand est aux antipodes de la conception
utilitariste
il est même le représentant du mouvement
opposé mouvements opposés qu'on appelle
généralement le déontologie sme
parce que le déontologie sme va
s'intéresser aux principes qui sont à
l'origine d'une action au principe
c'est-à-dire à la loi à la loi générale
qui nous commandent d'agir de telle ou
telle manière
dans un cas particulier
donc la morale qu'ancienne c'est une
morale du principe et c'est même une
morale de l'intention et c'est là on va
commencer à comprendre là la spécificité
de la morale kantienne c'est qu'une
action est jugée bonne si elle est
guidée par une bonne volonté la bonne
volonté
c'est la bonne intention c'est
l'intention qui correspond à l'idée du
bien
ce qui veut dire que pour quand une
action n'est pas bonne
simplement parce qu'elle correspond à ce
que prescrit la loi morale elle est
bonne parce qu'elle est animé par la
volonté d'être dans le bien une action
bonne pour compte n'est pas l'action
conforme à la loi morale c'est l'action
qui est animé par un respect de la loi
morale
ça c'est le premier aspect de la morale
kantienne qu'il faut vraiment garder à
l'esprit
et pour l'illustrer ch de prendre un
exemple très simple on va prendre
l'exemple du braqueur de banques qui
hésitent avant de commettre son braquage
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'ils hésitent la
visite pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'il a peur de se faire rattraper la
peur de se faire arrêter par les flics
et de finir en taule
donc qu'est ce qu'il fait est bien il
délibère intérieurement il se questionne
il réfléchit il se demande si tout bien
considéré il ne prend pas un risque trop
important
qu'est-ce qui va nourrir son hésitation
ce n'est pas un appel du bien ce n'est
pas un appel de sa bonne conscience
c'est tout simplement la prise en compte
du risque le risque de se retrouver en
prison
donc on peut dire que si le braqueur de
banques décident de renoncer à son geste
par peur de la prison par exemple on
pourrait dire que il agit moralement et
bien pour compte
non pour quand ce braqueur de banques
qu'ils renoncent à commettre son acte
par peur des conséquences
il n'est pas dans le bien il est dans la
conformité aux biens c'est à dire qu'il
agit comme si il était amoral
mais en réalité ce n'est pas parce qu'il
est morale qu'il renonce à son geste
et ça c'est quelque chose que quand tu
dénonces très vivement la conformité à
la loi morale qui n'est pas guidé qui
n'est pas motivée par une bonne volonté
qui n'est pas motivée par une volonté
d'être dans le bien donc on pourrait
dire si on voulait vraiment schématiser
que quand s'inscrit contre la morale de
l'hypocrisie la morale de l'hypocrisie
qui consiste à lutter avec ses désirs à
lutter avec ce que l'on veut faire parce
qu'on a conscience que c'est mal parce
qu'on a conscience que c'est contraire à
la loi morale mais finalement cette
conscience d'être dans le mal ne rend
pas notre intention de bonnes
donc quand s'oppose totalement à ce
schéma ce qui d'ailleurs rend sa
conception morale un petit peu
discutable parce que comment joue j'ai
l'intention de quelqu'un qui effectue
une action
comment savoir que son action est guidée
davantage par une bonne intention que
par une sorte de calcul une sorte de
recherche d'intérêt qui fait qu'on va
faire le choix de la morale mais presque
de manière accidentelle de manière
opportuniste même tout simplement parce
qu'on y trouve un intérêt
c'est l'idée que lorsque je donne une
pièce à un mendiant
je ne le fais pas parce que je suis
animé de l'intention de l'aider
je le fais pour satisfaire ma bonne
conscience c'est un petit peu ça l'idée
qu'on peut retrouver dans certaines
religions d'ailleurs mais que quand
récuse totalement la morale kantienne
est une morale de l'intention c'est une
morale qui repose sur la bonne volonté
qui repose sur la pureté de l'intention
alors est-ce que cet aspect suffit à
résumer la philosophie morale kantienne
est-ce qu'on peut réduire la morale de
quant à immoral de l'intention et bien
non parce que l'intention doit être
accouplé à une autre notion qu'on trouve
chez kant qui est justement la notion de
loi morale la loi morale pour compte
c'est véritablement ce qui doit guider
l'ensemble de nos actions et la loi
morale selon kant n'est pas quelque
chose
trouve en dehors de l'homme c'est à dire
que dans la plupart des conceptions
morales on considère qu'il y à un bien
qui est transcendant à l'homme un bien
qui est au dessus
c'est l'idée qu'on trouve là encore dans
les religions que nous devons suivre la
volonté de dieu
or chez quand on a pas du tout cette
idée là j'ai quand la loi morale n'est
pas imposée par une sorte d'autorité
extérieur toute puissante et omnisciente
la loi morale nous est imposée par nous
mêmes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que la loi
morale nous est imposée par vous même ça
veut dire que pour contre la loi morale
elle est présente de manière innée en
tout homme c'est ce qu'il appelle la
raison morale et c'est selon lui ce qui
fait réellement la différence entre
l'humanité et le reste des êtres vivants
l'être humain possède une raison morale
ce qu'on a l'habitude d'appeler une
conscience morale qui est pour ainsi
dire l'instant son intérieur de
l'autorité morale
l'instance intérieur de l'autorité
morale c'est l'idée que nous avons tous
en nous le principe du bien
nous avons tous en nous la loi morale à
laquelle nous devons obéir
alors là évidemment beaucoup
d'objections ont été faites à compte
notamment l'idée que les valeurs morales
les principes moraux sont d'abord des
acquis de la culture et de l'éducation
est la meilleure preuve en est que selon
les cultures
on ne considérera pas les mêmes choses
comme étant bonne ou mauvaise d'un
produit moral
on a ce qu'on appelle des singularités
moral donc c'est l'idée que la morale ne
serait pas quelque chose d'universel
ce serait quelque chose de
culturellement et historiquement
déterminée et c'est vrai qu'on en fait
tous l'expérience à notre propre échelle
il ya certaines choses qu'on considère
comme morale aujourd'hui ou en tout cas
qui ne s'oppose pas à la morale
aujourd'hui et qui pouvait être
considéré comme parfaitement immoral
au moyen-âge ou dans l'antiquité
donc les conceptions morales évoluent
elles évoluent dans le temps elles
évoluent dans l'espace comme dirait
pascal
vérité en deçà des pyrénées erreur
au-delà
ça signifie que selon le modèle culturel
dans lequel on va évoluer n'auront pas
forcément les mêmes conceptions morales
la question c'est de savoir est-ce que
cela met en échec la conception qu
ancien de la morale
eh bien non parce qu'en réalité c'est ce
qu'on appelle une morale formel c'est à
dire un cadre moral une structure morale
qui peut se retrouver de manière
universelle
indépendamment du contenu qu'on va
donner à la loi morale ce que veut dire
compte c'est que tous les hommes
possèdent une morale tous les hommes
possèdent une loi morale mais qu'ils ont
différentes manières de la mettre en
pratique
c'est comme si je vous disais que la
notion d'éducation existe partout et
pourtant ça ne veut pas dire que tout
les éducations sont identiques
le fait que l'éducation soit un concept
universel ne signifie pas que le contenu
de l'éducation soit le même partout
donc la loi morale selon quand elle se
caractérise par son universalité et
également par son caractère inné et les
fondements de la métaphysique des moeurs
c'est l'occasion que quand tu as trouvé
pour formuler précisément ce que selon
lui la loi morale nous dit quand nous
sommes confrontés
un choix moral donc c'est comme si quand
avait cherché à faire parler notre
conscience morale faire parler notre
raison morale pour lui faire dire ce
qu'elle nous dit de manière indicible de
manière parfois purement intuitive et
d'ailleurs c'est ça le but de la
démarche de compte c'est de rendre
consciente et explicite la loi morale
qui s'exprime en nous de manière parfois
inconsciente et intuitive
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à une
première formulation de la loi morale
kantienne plus exactement de l'impératif
catégorique qui est issu de cette loi
morale
voilà ce que nous dit la première
formulation de l'impératif catégorique
agit uniquement d'après la maxime qui
fait que tu puisse vouloir en même temps
qu'elle devienne une loi universelle
alors cette citation est assez connu
elle mérite qu'on s'y arrête un petit
peu qu'on la reformuler et qu'on la
décortique la première chose c'est que
cette formulation confirme ce qu'on
disait il ya quelques instants sur le
fait que la morale qu'ancienne est une
morale formelle c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'ont certains commentateurs récuse
l'expression même de morale kantienne
parce qu'en réalité quand ne propose pas
une morale il nous propose une structure
morale il nous propose un cadre moral et
le cadre moral compte c'est de dire que
on reconnaît la moralité d'une action au
fait que l'on pourrait vouloir que ceux
qui la guide soit partagé par tout le
monde on va le dire de manière encore un
peu plus simple lorsque vous vous
apprêtez à effectuer l'action et que
vous vous posez la question de savoir si
elle est morale ou pas posez vous la
question est ce que ce par quoi je suis
guidé actuellement je voudrais que cela
guide également toute l'humanité est ce
que je voudrais que toute l'humanité
soient guidés par le même principe
d'action qui est en train de me guider
actuellement c'est ça le test de
vérification de la morale chez quand
c'est le fait de passer cette épreuve de
l'universalisation du principe de mon
action le principe de mon action et
c'est de dire quelle est la loi qui me
parle
au moment où je choisis de lui obéir
quelle est la loi qui me dit que ce que
je m'apprête à faire est bien ou mal
et bien cette loi si je peux vouloir
qu'elle guide l'humanité à ce moment là
cela signifie que mon action et moral
alors faisons attention ici au
contresens habituelle qui consiste à
réduire cette proposition quant au
fameux adage ne fait pas à l'autre ce
que tu pas qu'il te fasse pas ce que ne
fait pas à l'autre ce que tu ne voudrais
pas qu'il te fasse cdu conséquentialiste
mme c'est l'idée que parce que je ne
voudrais pas subir telle ou telle chose
parce que ça produirait en moi de la
souffrance ou du déplaisir peu importe
pour cette raison là je ne voudrais pas
non plus l'appliquer à l'autre mais ça
c'est une morale des conséquences c'est
une morale de la prudence qui fait que
je ne vais pas me mettre en situation de
risque c'est exactement la même logique
que ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur
celui qui agit conformément à la loi
morale et non pas par respect de la loi
morale donc ne fais pas à autrui ce que
tu ne voudrais pas qu'il te fasse ce
n'est pas la morale contiennent donc là
quand il nous laisse un peu sur notre
faim parce que cette formulation de
l'impératif catégorique
mais concrètement elle ne dit pas ce que
l'on doit faire
elle ne dit pas quels axes les bonnes
quelle action mauvaise elle ne dit pas
quels sont les valeurs que l'on doit
incarner dans nos actions là pour
l'instant tout ce que nous dit quand
c'est que si on est ok pour que tout le
monde partage nos conceptions ça veut
dire que notre conception et morale
c'est peut-être un petit peu léger donc
au va accorder à quand le crédit de ses
intentions et on va les voir
immédiatement la deuxième formulation de
l'impératif catégorique la deuxième
formulation de l'impératif catégorique
elle et j'oserais dire un peu plus
intéressante parce qu'elle commence à
nous donner une idée du contenu que l'on
doit donner à notre action pour qu'elle
soit considérée comme une action morale
donc je vais maintenant vous lire la
deuxième formulation de l'impératif
catégorique c'est quand
j de telle façon que tu traites
l'humanité aussi bien dans ta personne
que dans tout autre toujours en même
temps comme fin et jamais simplement
comme moyen et là on a enfin une
formulation du contenu de l'action
morale selon quand l'action morale c'est
celle qui est guidé par la notion de
dignité
qu'est ce que c'est que la dignité c'est
la valeur particulière qu'a l'être
humain et qu'est ce qui confère cette
valeur particulière à l'être humain
c'est le fait qu'il soit doté d'une
raison morale
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler dans mon
débat avec aq et éthiques
sur le légalisme ce qui structure la
notion de dignité humaine
c'est le fait que les êtres humains
soient porteurs d'une raison morale qui
fait qu'ils se posent la question de la
bonté ou part de leurs actes alors bien
entendu on peut critiquer cette
conception de la dignité peut dire comme
le font les utilitaristes que ce n'est
qu'une invention une abstraction
métaphysique qui ne repose sur rien de
matériel
mais toujours est il que pour quand
l'homme possède un statut particulier
parmi les êtres
il est doué d'une conscience morale et
les doigts d'une raison morale et en ce
sens il a une valeur particulière qu'il
appelle la dignité
là où les êtres inanimé eux vont pas de
dignité mais ont un prix la valeur de la
chose inanimée chez compte c'est le prix
la valeur de l'être humain c'est la
dignité et donc l'idée de quand c'est de
dire que parce que l'être humain possède
une dignité
il ne peut pas être traité comme une
chose il ne peut pas être traité comme
un être inanimé qui n'a qu'un prix mais
qui n'a pas de dignité
donc quand opère une séparation radicale
entre l'être humain qui possède une
dignité entre les choses qui possède un
prix
et c'est ça qui conditionne
intégralement son impératif catégorique
l'impératif catégorique cindy qu'une
action est moralement bonne quand dans
notre manière de traiter l'humanité nous
ne voyons pas en l'autre un moyen pour
satisfaire notre intérêt nous y voyons
un être humain à part entière un être
humain qui n'appartient qu'à lui un être
humain sur lequel je n'ai pas de droit
d'appropriation et le fait que je n'ai
pas de droit d'appropriation de l'autre
c'est ce qui m'interdit de considérer
l'autre comme un objet c'est ce qui
m'interdit de le considérer comme un
moyen c'est ce qui m'interdit de me
servir de lui à son détriment
pour parvenir à mes fins donc vous voyez
que la rhône a quand même un pas
supplémentaire qui est franchie par
rapport à la première formulation
l'impératif catégorique c'est à dire qu
on a l'idée d'une dignité humaine qui
doivent structurer l'ensemble de nos
comportements
et vous remarquerez quelque chose de
très intéressant c'est que quand tu
appliques ce traitement de l'humanité
non seulement aux autres mais aussi à
soi même
ça veut dire que pour quand on se
comporte de manière immorale
lorsque l'on ne se traite pas soi même
comme une fin en soi c'est à dire
lorsqu'on ne respecte pas sa propre
dignité et qu'est ce que c'est notre
dignité
et bien c'est précisément le fait qu'on
ne se considère pas comme chose on se
considère pas comme un objet on se
considère comme ayant une valeur
supplémentaire
on se considère comme ayant une
signification supplémentaires et cette
signification c'est précisément le fait
que nous serions capables de distinguer
entre le bien et le mal
cette capacité que nous avons à obéir
non pas à une autorité extérieure qui
s'imposent à nous mais à une partie de
nous-mêmes qui est universellement
partagé le fait de se comporter
moralement selon compte c'est la
démonstration de notre appartenance à
l'humanité et le fait d'agir de manière
immorale
c'est le fait de s'exclure soi même du
cercle de l'humanité donc vous voyez que
la morale qu'ancienne ce n'est pas une
morale qui nous permet de faire des
compromis avec notre conscience
on ne joue pas avec la morale on ne
plaisante pas avec la morale et c'est ce
qui a fait dire à certains que la morale
de comptes étaient trop désincarné pour
avoir une réelle pertinence dans la vie
réelle je crois que c'est charles péguy
qui disait la morale qu'on sienne a les
mains pures mais elle n'a pas demain la
pas demain c'est à dire elle n'est pas
confrontée à la réalité dans tout ce que
la réalité peut avoir parfois de
compliqué de plus contradictoires la
réalité qui est faite de dilemme
permanent et où la direction du bien de
nous apparaît pas forcément
immédiatement
je me souviens que lorsque j'ai étudié
la morale de comptes en fac de
philosophie notre professeur s'amuser à
imaginer des situations pratiques dans
lesquels on essaierait d'appliquer la
morale kantienne et on se rendait compte
que c'était extrêmement compliqué parce
que parfois certaines situations nous
tiraille entre deux exigences
entre deux impératifs moraux qui ont
autant de valeur l'un que l'autre
qui ne sont pas compatibles un exemple
qu'on peut prendre c'est celui du
mourant qui est maintenue en vie
artificiellement et qui nous confronte à
la question est ce qu'il vaut mieux le
maintenir en vie
quoi qu'il en coûte ou est ce qu'il vaut
mieux ne pas le faire souffrir davantage
parce que dans ces deux cas là la notion
de dignité humaine est impliqué qu'est
ce qui fait la valeur de la vie humaine
c'est la dignité humaine et est ce que
la dignité humaine est encore respectée
lorsque l'on fait souffrir inutilement
quelqu'un
donc finalement dans cette situation du
patient qui souffre et dont on veut
protéger la vie est ce qu'on n'est pas
en train de contredire le principe de
dignité humaine en voulant le défendre
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de faire
le mal en voulant faire le bien donc ça
c'est le genre d'exemple on pourrait
objecter acompte qui aurait sans doute
une réponse je ne me permettrais pas de
faire la réponse à sa place mais le fait
est que la morale de kant a donné lieu à
de nombreuses critiques qui porte
principalement sur cette dimension la
pureté de l'intention qui ne semble pas
coïncider avec la réalité quotidienne du
questionnement moral
une autre chose qui a été reproché à la
morale de compte qui d'ailleurs
s'inscrit dans le prolongement de ce
qu'on vient dire c'est qu'elle nous
porte parfois agir sans porter
d'attention aux conséquences de nos
actes la morale kantienne étant une
morale de l'intention morale du principe
ça signifie qu'on ne doit pas se poser
la question des conséquences de nos
actes puisque les conséquences que
constitue en aucun cas un critère
d'évaluation moral donc par exemple
c'est ce qui fait dire à compte que le
mensonge doit être bannie quelle que
soit la situation
quelles que soient les circonstances le
mensonge est condamnable
quelle que soit la situation quel que
soit le contexte
alors pourquoi est-ce que le mensonge
est condamnable déjà bien justement
parce que il considère à traiter l'autre
comme un moyen le moyen de notre
supercherie le moyen de notre ruse le
moyen de notre malhonnêteté et donc en
mentant à quelqu'un on ne considère pas
comme un être humain doté d'une dignité
pour le considère simplement comme un
objet que l'on peut manipuler donc le
mensonge est interdit il est interdit en
toutes circonstances ça veut dire que si
un criminel poursuit sa victime et qu'il
vous demande quel chemin elle a pris eh
bien vous avez le devoir selon kant de
l'udps ya la vérité vous avez le devoir
de lui indiquer la direction qu'a prise
la victime parce que si vous ne le
faites pas vous traiter l'autre comme un
moyen et dans ce cas là vous allez à
l'encontre de la loi morale
vous imaginez évidemment le genre de
déconvenue auquel peut mener le respect
intégral de l'impératif catégorique de
quand vous voyez qu'on est quand même
toujours dans l'idée d'une forme de
déconnexion avec la réalité une sorte
sorte d'idéalisme morale que beaucoup de
philosophes ultérieures ont considéré
comme n'étant tout simplement pas
réaliste et d'ailleurs et nous pourrons
conclure la vidéo là dessus ce n'est pas
un hasard si au fil du temps le terme de
morale a fini par prendre une
connotation passablement négative
lorsque l'on entend le mot morale on
pense tout de suite à des règles
contraignantes on pense à la rigidité
on pense à la moraline ce que certains
ont appelé la moraline pour parler
justement du côté donneur de leçons du
côté moralisateur qu'on peut trouver
dans la philosophie de compte et qu'on
peut trouver d'une manière générale dans
certaines de nos considérations morales
il y à cette idée de juger l'acte de
l'autre à la lumière d'un principe
abstrait à la lumière d'une règle que
l'on estime universel et dont nous
sommes parfois très pro a constaté
qu'elle a été enfreinte par l'autre mais
rarement par soi et pour justement
marqué la distinction avec cette
connotation du terme moral on a vu se
développer usage du mot éthique
remplacer le terme de morale alors
l'éthique
il semble faire référence à quelque
chose qui est plus souple voire à
quelque chose de plus personnel que la
morale avoir une éthique c'est avoir des
principes d'action mais des principes
d'action qui ne font pas forcément sous
tendue par le bien et le mal comme
absolu c'est l'idée que le bien et le
mal sont des notions plus relative et
que sur une échelle entre le bien absolu
et le mal absolu
il existe une infinité de variations il
existe un dégradé quasiment infinies un
peu comme le spectre chromatique nous
amène du blanc au noir en passant par
une infinité de nuances et finalement je
ne trouverai pas absurde que la morale
kantienne puisse se trouver confronté à
elle même parce que c'est justement tout
l'ambition de la philosophie de kant que
de nous appeler à l'autonomie que de
nous appeler à l'indépendance que de
nous appeler à la responsabilité
individuelle et de la même façon que
quand nous disait que les lumières
étaient le moment où l'humanité devenait
adulte peut-être sa philosophie morale
aussi rigide soit elle doit elle nous a
mené à une conception plus responsable
plus mature de la morale
une conception qui ne soit pas
uniquement d'idées par la conformité
d'une action ou bien ou au mal et
peut-être cagire moralement ce serait
davantage questionner nos intentions
questionner nos motivations questionner
ce qui s'exprime ce qui se manifeste en
nous qu'est ce qui nous guide
qu'est ce qui nous anime qu'est ce qui
mobilise notre âme
c'est peut-être ça la question la plus
importante plutôt que de savoir si ce
que l'on s'apprête à faire est conforme
ou pas à la représentation culturelle
du bien et du mal évidemment je
laisserais chacun d'entre vous répondre
qu'on lui même j'espère que cette vidéo
aura cru est intéressé n'oubliez pas la
partager
n'oubliez pas lalique et et de la
commenter pensez à me rejoindre sur les
réseaux sociaux tous les liens sont dans
la description
je remercie infiniment tous les
donateurs qui font que cette chaîne
existe parce que je ne répéterai jamais
assez cette chaîne existe d'abord parce
que vous êtes là je vous dis à bientôt
pour une prochaine vidéo et d'ici là
comme d'habitude
soyez sages
[Musique]